[Music]
goes to game keep the secret and this
there learn Sophia let's talk about the
introduction to Pretty Little Liars the
perfectionist which of course we'll
start with the theme song and the
opening credits Pretty Little Liars had
an iconic one but when you did approach
this opening credit sequence what did
you want to be different about it well
we wanted to be similar in the sense
that even you know the Pretty Little
Liars the the logo is the same font but
then the perfectionist is its own thing
so throughout the the creation of this
series it's always been trying to find
that balance of giving fans enough of
the PLL world that that tone that that
vibe but yet bring something really new
to it and yep that we're using the song
but it's got a little bit of a twist to
it right if yeah breathing liars but
with a little but here's what I'm saying
we know that the two of you have an
amazing voice so does Sophia I wanted
the three device to do a little song
these days just please love you will do
it for fun it's a new version of the
song and its iconic in a way that I
don't even know if Sophia knows this yet
but every episode there'll be one shot
of the intro that that is an Easter egg
of something that's to come in the
episode I can do that that's really cool
sort of our version of the PLL closer's
whoa kind of like Ozark do me over
watching XR cos our opening hurt that
kind of show you like for little images
about something that's to come you know
I actually know that who or what I
actually love about that is they're
always used to be this slight random
ending on PLL it was like you know this
thing that will happen in the future so
that's a different way of doing it she
gives out these gonna be little thing
nation that I got to hear the rain we
all have secrets I've been in your shoes
what are you gonna do
nothing I haven't done before
[Music]